So once we see these two things next to each other, it
kind of raises the question, why, don't we just use a gradient decent type
,on an error metric that's defined in terms of y, hat instead of
this, the activation a? because y hat ,is the thing, that we really
want to match the output. We don't really want the activation to
match the output. There's no, there's no need for that. So, it seemed
there's a, bunch of different possible reasons for that. It could be, well
we don't do that, because, it
would just be computationally compactable. It's too,
it's too much work. Another possibility ,would be, well to
do the gradient descent, you'd have to be able to take
the derivitive and if we use it in this form,
it's not differentiable. So, we can't take the derivative. Another one
is, well sure we can do all that, it's not
intractable and its not, not differentiable. But, if we do that
then the weights tend to grow too fast, until you
end up getting unstable answers, and then, the last possible choice
that we will give you is. You can do
that but you can get multiple different answers and
the different answers, behave differently and so this is
really just to keep it from being in illdefined.